إذن ، هذه هي خطتنا للأيام
والأسابيع المقبلة
أولاً ،
لقد أنشأنا فريقًا جديدًا للمساعدة في قيادة هذه
المهمة الجديدة
اعتبارًا من اليوم قمنا بتعليق
وجودنا الدبلوماسي في كابول
ونقلنا عملياتنا إلى الدوحة قطر
والتي سيتم إخطارها رسميًا قريبًا
للكونغرس  البيئة الأمنية غير
المستقرة والوضع السياسي في أفغانستان
، كانت الخطوة الحكيمة التي يجب
اتخاذها واسمحوا لي أن أغتنم هذه
الفرصة لأشكر معرض التهم المعلقة
وسفير كابول روس ويلسون الذي
خرج من التقاعد في يناير 2020
لقيادة سفارتنا في
أفغانستان وقد فعل  عمل شجاع استثنائي
خلال وقت صعب للغاية
في الوقت الحالي
، سنستخدم هذا المنصب في الدوحة
لإدارة دبلوماسيتنا مع أفغانستان
بما في ذلك الشؤون القنصلية
إدارة المساعدة
الإنسانية والعمل مع شركاء الحلفاء
وأصحاب المصلحة الإقليميين والدوليين
لتنسيق مشاركتنا
ورسائلنا إلى طالبان
سيقود فريقنا هناك إيان
مكاريك الذي يخدم  كنائب رئيس
بعثتنا في أفغانستان للعام الماضي ،
لم يكن هناك من هو أفضل استعدادًا للقيام بهذه المهمة
ثانيًا ، سنواصل
جهودنا الدؤوبة لمساعدة
الرعايا الأمريكيين والأفغان على مغادرة
أفغانستان إذا اختاروا
السماح لي بالتحدث بإيجاز عن الأمريكيين
الذين بقوا في أفغانستان
أفغانستان ، لقد بذلنا جهودًا غير عادية
لمنح الأمريكيين كل
فرصة لمغادرة البلاد
في كثير من الحالات ، تحدثنا وأحيانًا
إلى
مطار أولئك الذين عرّفوا بأنفسهم على أنهم
أمريكيون في أفغانستان والذين
يفكرون في مغادرة البلاد ، تلقينا
حتى الآن تأكيدًا بأن
تم إجلاء ستة آلاف أو غادروا بطريقة أخرى ،
ومن المرجح أن يستمر هذا العدد في النمو
مع استمرار وصولنا والوافدين ،
نعتقد أنه لا يزال هناك عدد صغير
من الأمريكيين
أقل من 200 وربما أقرب إلى 100
ممن بقوا في أفغانستان ويريدون
المغادرة
ونحن نحاول  لتحديد
عدد
البيانات التي نمر بها بالضبط
والاتصال وإرسال الرسائل النصية  على الرغم من وجود قوائمنا
وسيكون لدينا المزيد من التفاصيل لمشاركتها في
أقرب وقت ممكن ، فإن
جزءًا من التحدي مع تحديد
رقم دقيق
هو أن هناك مقيمين في أفغانستان منذ فترة طويلة
لديهم جوازات
سفر أمريكية وكانوا يحاولون تحديد ما إذا
كانوا يريدون ذلك أم لا  ترك
العديد من المواطنين الأمريكيين مزدوجي الجنسية ولديهم
جذور عميقة وعائلات ممتدة في
أفغانستان والذين أقاموا هناك
لسنوات عديدة ، إنه خيار مؤلم
يستمر التزامنا تجاههم وتجاه جميع الأمريكيين في أفغانستان وفي كل مكان في العالم